Joe so the question is so you want to
bridge the gap or is it your way or uh
the highway anyway Biden seems intent on
taking your earnings hostage now the IRS
they just announced this week that they
want to start tracking all of the tips
that workers earn so that they can be
taxed for it uh so so much for Biden's
sacred promise not to raise taxes on
anyone making less than four hundred
thousand dollars a year remember this is
all part of Biden's so-called inflation
reduction act now that just took effect
on January 1st by the way what nobody
seems to want to talk about in the media
that bill that went in into place this
year includes let's see uh the money to
hire another 87 000 IRS agents here now
with reaction is the host of making
money on Fox Business our friend Charles
Payne but it also includes uh a lot of
taxes hundreds of billions of dollars in
new taxes that impact people that make
less some four hundred thousand dollars
a year Charles correct me if I'm wrong
did this bill that went into effect
January 1 did that put new taxes on coal
and oil and natural gas did it put new
taxes on people's pensions and
retirements did it put new taxes 250
billion on corporations and corporations
don't pay taxes they pass it on to we
the consumers so didn't he already break
the 400 000 a year mark that he laid out
for himself
absolutely Sean uh 225 billion of
corporate minimum tax again we know
where that money will have to come from
uh 1.2 billion coal tax you know think
about the folks in that area who are
going to get hammered 6.5 billion
natural gas tax a 12 billion dollar
crude oil tax and all of this you know
it goes directly toward folks mostly
overwhelmingly making less than four
hundred thousand dollars a year and you
know you talk about this this tip uh
this they're looking for money in the
tip area this is what happens when you
want big government it's Insidious it's
got to look under every put every pillow
cushion it must do it you know there's
notion about taxing the rich I get so
sick of it you know uh going after so
supposedly Jeff Bezos no the kind of
government that they're trying to build
think about this EV program the electric
vehicle program they offer 30 billion
dollars to these manufacturers it's
already up to 140 billion dollars where
do they get this money from so you go
after tips somehow they say you know
what companies employers that are
supposed to report this tip income we
figured about a lot of them don't they
rounded it off to about one point uh was
it 1.7 billion dollars they want that
money and and so it's going to happen to
people making the lowest incomes in this
country you know what the federal
minimum wage is for tip workers this is
President Biden he's always talking
about raise the minimum wage is two
dollars and 13 cents you talk about
folks who survived off of tips they
shouldn't be taxed on any of them I
really I really don't even I always give
a cash let me ask you I hope they put it
in their pocket okay I wanna I wanna
debunk this myth that is out there
because he brought it up last night Big
Oil big farmer uh billionaires don't pay
their fair share
um okay first of all the top one percent
of wage earners they pay anywhere
between 42 and 50 percent of of income
taxes in this country the bottom 50
percent pays less than two percent
that's number one and to get to his
calculation that billionaires don't pay
their fair share doesn't that include
the top 400 wealthiest Americans and the
money that they have invested in stocks
in the stock market in other words
unrealized income that might be worth a
hundred dollars a share today but by the
time they cash it out maybe it's worth a
dollar so we don't really know what that
income is until they cash it out isn't
that true so isn't that disingenuous or
dishonest accounting
is disingenuous and it's dangerous
imagine if this had gone into effect two
years ago and then we had the year we
had last year you know at one point Jeff
Bezos lost maybe 100 200 billion dollars
on paper so one year he pays 100 billion
in taxes and next year he loses 200
billion it's asinine they're going they
say they're going after these folks but
people watching this show watch their
retirements suffer they're going to be
the real victims and they'll pay the
money for the new natural gas tax call
tax oil tax taxes on their pensions and
watch corporations raise their rates all
right Charles Payne thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else